Hey traders, it's Mike here and in this
video I'm going to talk about one of my
favorite setups. You know, it's an
exhaustion setup that you can see in the
order flow, especially when it comes
after absorption. And today in the
S&P's, you know, there was a bearish
example and a nice bullish example. So,
you know, today in the S&P's we hit our
high of the day up here at 7450 and a
half and we just sort of went sideways,
okay? And you know, going up into the
high, we had nice positive deltas that
you can see right here. You know, it
went 152, 190, 276, 727. We're up here
at the high and then we just went
sideways at the high up here. And as we
were going
sideways at the high, we actually
started putting in some negative deltas.
It started increasing
negative, went from minus eight, which
is small, to minus 91, minus 129 as we
are just going sideways right here.
Now, what makes this interesting is is a
few things, okay? So, obviously we had
the deltas starting to grow negative up
here at the high. You know, that that's
not a good sign if you're at the high of
the day. You know, you don't want to
start seeing negative delta and more
importantly, you don't want to be seeing
negative delta that is getting stronger,
okay? And another thing [clears throat]
that was interesting is, you know, we
have these five bars right here with the
point of control more or less at the
same price. We got one, two, three, four
and another point of control just one
tick lower. Okay? So, now we're we're
starting to go sideways, it's obvious.
But more importantly, the delta's
getting stronger. Now, this is where it
got really interesting is looking at the
volumes. First time we hit the high, we
got 107. Second time, 19.
Third time, just two. We had this nice
exhaustion print right here, the two.
Okay? It's got a bearish ratio of 48,
which indicates price exhaustion. So,
we're going sideways
at the high of the day.
Anytime you're at the high of the day,
you always got to be asking, you know,
can we go higher? Or if we're not going
to go higher, obviously you got to start
looking for signs of Um, maybe the
market's going to go sideways, which is
what it just happened here from
basically 11:25 to, you know, more or
less 11:35. So, for 10 minutes we went
sideways. Okay, but now you got to start
looking for clues.
Now that we're going sideways, what's
going to happen? Is aggressive buying
picking up, meaning that we're going to
go higher, or is aggressive selling in
control? Okay? And what actually we have
here, right? I mentioned the exhaustion
print of two up here with the bearish
ratio. To me, that's telling me this
market doesn't want to go higher. We hit
the high, 107 contracts traded on the
offer, hit the high again, 19 traded on
the offer, hit the high a third time,
two just traded on the offer, too.
Okay? So,
what's that telling you? Well, do
aggressive buyers really want to take
this higher? No, because why is it only
trading two contracts? You're not
looking for this market to go up. If
anything, it's starting to show weakness
with the delta being negative up here
with that exhaustion print here. And
again, you know, the beauty of it is
where's your stop? It's just right here
at the high, or just a tick above the
high. You could get short anywhere in
here around, you know, the 7448
and a half, 7449 area. And then what
happens? Boom, the market sells all the
way down below 7438, right? That's 10
points from 48 right here.
That's 10
10 full points in what? 1 2 3 4 5
minutes.
Now, that was the bearish example.
Let me talk about the bullish example.
So, you know, we hit that low, not that
low. We came off from that high, hit the
swing low around 11:43 Chicago time. And
then,
you know, just just draw this line here.
So, this is our new swing low, right?
From that high.
And a little bit later, around 12:15,
12:30, we start coming back down to that
low.
Now, what was interesting this time
Okay.
We went sideways here. We actually
started going sideways a bit here.
But this area in here
Okay, remember this blue line here is
our swing low.
Right here.
So we're coming down into that area.
Right now it's a swing low for a reason.
But we hit it once
twice, three, four times.
All right. Now look at this Delta. The
first time we get down to that area it's
minus 504. Second time minus 139. Third
time minus 105. Fourth time minus 53. So
we're coming down trying to test this
line here which is our swing low.
Strong selling minus 504. Okay. Next bar
opens up pushes down a few ticks.
Doesn't get to that low but the
aggressive selling ends up being a bit
weaker. It's only minus 139. We do it
again a third time minus 105. A fourth
time
minus 53.
Okay, but more importantly look at these
volumes. 85 174. So there was some
strong interest. Right? It even went
offered here for 46 contracts offered
here for 74. But then in this green bar
right here
one
is exhaustion print. It's got bullish
ratio of 305 which indicates exhaustion.
Next bar this doji candle. Now doji
candles tend to be not really
important in my form of order flow
analysis. But nevertheless it comes down
to that same level trades three which is
also an exhaustion print. You don't see
a ratio because it's a doji candle.
But nevertheless if you're looking at
the Delta
504 minus 139 minus 105 minus 53. So you
know it's getting weaker. Coming into
that area.
That aggressive selling isn't present.
Just as earlier right? When we're up
here at the high,
we saw sort of the opposite with the
aggressive buying weakening 107.19 and
two.
Okay? And then,
you know, just
another important thing was this bar
here.
We have the bullish engulfing value
area, the bullish prominent point of
control, the bullish value area that's
not traded into in this bar here, which
again is very bullish. And what happens?
You know, the market went up, but again,
you know, from the 74.38 area,
right, we went all the way up back up to
where we were earlier at 74.50. So, you
know, 74
>> [sighs]
>> you know, 38 right here
up to 74.48, it's 10 points. Just as you
had 10 points on the downside. Okay,
with very similar read in the market.
And again, what
the important thing is we were coming
into a level. This was our level. Why
was this our level here, this blue line?
Well, that whoops.
That was our swing low that we had made
right here. Just as up here, this was
our level. What level was that? Well,
that was our high of the day, right?
Right here, this was our high of the
day.
So, again, you know, the the key
takeaway from this lesson
is when you're coming into a level,
whether it's the high of the day or
swing high or swing low or even your own
levels that you determine using say
market profile or volume profile or
pivots or whatever, look for that
exhaustion.
Look at what's happening in terms of the
delta. In this case, up here at the
high, we got the negative delta
increasing, right? Going into this high,
we had positive delta increasing 15
That's what you want to see when you go
into a high. But once you're at the
high, you don't want to start seeing
negative deltas getting
bigger, growing,
which you saw up here. Just as when
we're down here at this level,
now,
we don't see the
aggressive buying coming in until later,
but more importantly, we did see This is
our level, the blue line. Remember, we
saw the minus 504, minus 139, minus 105,
minus 53, even to the minus 11 here.
The delta, the aggressive selling down
into this level, into this blue line
here,
which was our support level,
was decreasing. It was getting weaker.
And then we're seeing the signs of
exhaustion
in the order flow by the exhaustion
prints
right before the market turned and went
higher. And again, what kind of risk do
you have on this trade? Well, your stop
just goes right down here below this
swing low, right?
You know, and if you're getting long
here, 38, 39, somewhere in here,
you know, you're talking 38, 39.
You know, this is your risk,
but this is your reward.
All right, everyone. So, I hope you
enjoyed this video.
And you know, be sure to check out my
channel for more videos.